well he said he's going to get on a
plane I guess tomorrow yeah I think he's
still in France right now uh uh yeah
he's coming to Los Angeles first week of
August so that we can start like casting
and location scouting and stuff oh great
so the two of you will go actually
together to Palo Alto and figure out
where yeah I like working with Vlad
because um you know it's really hard
sometimes to work with another director
like as co-directors because you don't
have the same vision but I'm really
lucky because we do have the same vision
and like the same ideas and we want
things done the exact same way and like
I believe that he's better at certain
things than I am and I hope that he
thinks the same so like you know I feel
like we're gonna work together really
well yeah that's a good point about
creative partnerships it's like knowing
when to defer to one person and knowing
where one person's strengths lie versus
you know and how do you how do you
balance that if you're in a creative
partnership with someone and they have a
set idea and you also have a set idea
how do you find that middle ground or do
you fight for what you want jar you are
you kinda you like to go up to bat for
what you see is the way you want it I
mean yeah I do like to do that like um
there's definitely like certain things
that I'm very particular about like some
of the characters like are they come
from like myself so that's something
that's really important but I think it's
also important when you're working as a
team to like be able to compromise and
to be able to like think about knotts
best for you but what's best for the
project well that's a good point yeah
three times like you know I've been able
to see like you know let glad take the
rain on some things and he's been very
good about letting me take the rain on
others you know so we've never really
thought about anything which I was
surprised about I wasn't surprised